we need to look at a company and try to
assess how risky is it how much should
we price the insurance for that kind of
a company and that is a
fascinating task it's a it's a
fascinating challenge for us to crack
down and and
the yeah and the the the the last piece
of it is after the company is already H
purchasing insurance and they are
Insurance of ours and we share the risk
from a a financial
perspective um we want to keep them at
at a minimal risk and want to keep them
as safe as possible and we do a lot of
efforts around that including active
risk monitoring and er building security
products that serve them in a way that
will reduce risk for all of us we we
share the risk we partner on the risk to
to an
[Music]
extent Benish lener welcome to 20 minute
leaders I'm very excited to have you
here thank you so much for joining me
thank you Michael for inviting me I am
really really excited I really like ad
Bay and I think the what you're doing is
really awesome I think that looking into
the future of cyber security threats on
small businesses and organizations and
looking at what how insurance is sort of
like this oldest idea a and modernizing
it to fit the needs of where the risks
are they're not just in earthquakes
they're not just in in incidents and in
accidents in the office H now we have
new forms of risks that are rising so
I'm excited to learn a little bit more
about that and what are these risks that
we're experiencing and how adbay works
but also your own Journey ER VP of cyber
Technologies within within ATB
previously director product management
and some phenomenal companies including
a checkpoint so it's so really really
amazing uh uh background tell me a
little bit about the St that were're in
cyber Insurance what does this even mean
yeah so um cyber insurance is obviously
a financial Tool uh of insurance to um
deal with and cover any losses that are
related to cyber security
attacks um with the the growth in in
cyber risk and and and as we see more
and more uh types of attacks and the and
higher levels of sophistication of
attacks in past
years um companies had to find ways to
deal with the this kind of a risk of
getting hit by a ransomware attack or it
could be a financial fraud or a business
email
compromise um breaches of data of all
sorts and in some types of companies
also um ways to hold manufacturing for
example these kinds of the risks are are
fundamental and they're they're
existential for for a lot of the
organizations on the other hand building
uh the the defenses that a company needs
is not trivial at all especially when it
comes to um hiring the right people
foring the the the best Solutions out
there um so these These are challenges
that not all organizations are dealing
with very well so they're getting in
insurance instead of that on our end as
a as an insurance
provider it's it's
also an
interesting an interesting challenge we
need to look at a company and try to
assess how risky is it how much should
we price the insurance for that kind of
a company and that is a fascinating
task it's a it's a fascinating challenge
for us to crack down and and
the yeah and the the the the last piece
of it is after the company is already H
purchasing insurance and they are
Insurance of ours and we share the risk
from a a financial
perspective um we want to keep them at
at a minimal risk and want to keep them
as safe as possible and we do a lot of
efforts around that including active
risk monitoring and building security
products that serve them in a way that
will reduce risk for all of us we we
share the risk we partner on the risk to
to an extent AB absolutely H how do you
quantify risk for a lot of these things
because I imagine that you can come to a
building in a home and look at the
status of the and the condition of the
roof and uh you can assume a certain
risk given a certain rainfall
how how do you assess risk on cyber
security
threats yep so um first of all we're
trying to look at it from the eyes of
the hacker if I was if I was an hacker
how would I be looking at this company
and would I be able to see any cracks in
the walls or any any open windows I can
try to get in through which I can try
and get in um so we are scanning the the
the customers in a way that a hacker
would to try and find the how to get in
and we're looking also at other um at
other pieces of data that we have uh
things that are related to the industry
the company works at obviously the the
annual revenue uh kind of
the um quantifies the the the size of
the Target right a larger company you
can extort more than than a very small
company um so we're looking at the
firmographic data we're looking at H the
tax stack that we can identify even
things that are not vulnerable per se
but we do know them as a ways for some
hackers to get in uh are things that
we're looking at
and so all all of that together and it's
an ongoing challenge things change all
the time in this space we see hackers H
changing the way they conduct uh their
attacks and and we see defenses change
and we need to keep track of all of that
all of the
time and and eventually the the the
advantage that we have here is that we
that the insurance uh business is coming
with a lot of tools to quantify risk so
we have loss ratios frequencies
severities a bunch of the terms and and
the words that I've learned um when I
just joined that bay and joined this
world of insurance but actually they
they have a lot of tools and as you said
it's not an
ancient craft yeah insurance but it is
it has like 200 years 250 years of
practices and so we're we're using that
and marrying these two um world
of in of the in cyber security and
insurance bringing in the best of of
these two worlds together and that's
that that's what we do that's that's the
interesting part I love it and you know
um we're we're talking about about deep
fakes and about synthetic media this is
one example of a new form of risk which
you know is is coming it's it's
appearing in different ways and it also
shows that it it has different ways of
of costing the organization right in
some cases there's the $25 million heist
in other cases they hack the admin of G
Suite it's two different quantities of
risk which I don't even know how to even
quantify that so how do so looking at
these types of
risks that are either a little bit into
the future or they're emerging or that
they're looking more into the social
engineering fishing State how do you as
an insurer quantify that risk you know
you have to sort of look into the future
while also having the Dynamics of
looking at the different attack vectors
yeah exactly so looking at the at the
rare mirror is always easier and that's
what usually insurance does because when
you look at most of of the areas of
insurance like home insurance or or
autom mobile
Insurance uh usually they have
credibility of of multiple years in the
past MH uh the way that uh car accidents
happen did not dramatically change over
the last few years maybe with more uh
autonomous cars it will change but for
now the risk is pretty much the same for
us it changes all the time so we do uh
look back um as much as we can and we
are keeping track of recent couple of
years it is still indicative into future
risks um
and the the interesting thing is that we
have uh around
37,000 um companies that are insured by
us so every year we gain 37,000 years of
of experience in being uh at the at the
drive the driver's seat or at least next
to the driver's seat for 37,000 the smbs
um so we use that a lot other than that
we're we're using our imagination and
we're trying to um to predict what's
what's next for example deep fakes used
to get in or to to create some kind of a
financial fraud we believe in many cases
it will H realize itself in in financial
fraud
um um so it's that kind of a game
usually we will not be acting on
something that has that wasn't
Quantified and full so until we actually
see claims coming in from in this
case big fake Financial frauds probably
it will be very hard for us to uh to
quantify that and to to Really price it
out but and I think it sounds like that
the the fact that you're sitting and and
you're get you're getting the sort of
Bird's I view on 37,000 smes you really
are you probably have the best eyes on
where what is the state of threats for
smbs right this is I mean you're
literally seeing the claims this you're
seeing the pain as it happens and then
you can aggregate it and so I I think
that it's a it's a phenomenal place to
be and I I want to hear a little bit
about your own journey and about your
own sort of progression from the Hebrew
University to different
institutions product you know tell me a
little bit about yourself yeah um so I
I've been with computers from relatively
young age um and uh I I started
programming in elementary school some
basic things um but somewhere when I was
growing up I I wanted to do a little bit
more I wanted to get out of the sheer
technical ER perspective of how to build
how to engineer things ER rather into
business oriented things and as as as I
came as went to the to my Army service
and then ER I had to decide or came to
to the point where I decide what to
study I I really wanted to
somehow um find a way to to um do
something that is related to um to
computer science to computers in general
but also have uh a business aspect to it
so I I started this um program uh in the
Hebrew University for computer science
and and the an MBA at the same time um
and when I was done with the my studies
and I joined another friend to to
co-found um a basically an NGO in Israel
that um aimed to change the way that
other NOS are using
technology specifically there was one
big ER the relatively large project that
we did the
in partnership with the government and
some leading um some leading
um NOS or or
um organizations that oversee the the
third the third sector in Israel H to
build uh a platform for transparency for
it's called guar it still is active and
it is managed by the Department of
Justice here in Israel it's it's the
same model as
was created in the US um so for me
personally it was a very very
interesting uh experience I learned so
much there I had a chance to do a lot of
mistakes in this kind of a
Sandbox
um did a lot of interesting things and
and it did take me out of the the scope
of being a programmer or doing only the
technical stuff from there I moved to um
at some point I had to grow up a little
bit and get out of the NGO space and um
I I happened to I I didn't want to go to
an Enterprise to a larger company but I
happened to um get accepted into
checkpoint which is more or less the
largest you'll find in Israel at least
at that time um and I I started to learn
about cyber security and into more depth
and the
um also about the the enterprise
software world and how how the the
business mechanics work um and that was
fascinating and at least in Tel Aviv
it's very hard to learn all of that in
any other company other than than
checkpoint which is headquartered here
and takes all the decisions here in Tel
Aviv um so that that was an amazing
school for me
um the there were very interesting
things in working for checkpoint like a
lot of business orientation on the other
hand I always felt that it wasn't proper
product management as it is done in
other places it lacks a little bit the
Hands-On ER part of product management
actually writing the the requirements
working on the user experience into
details and all of that so they decided
to move to sel one it was a little bit
before they went public and
and it was a hell
gide um it's a it's a it's a spaceship
at least at that time it was a spaceship
it was still um 2021 and the and
everything was moving very very fast
hyper growth um it was a super super
um and teach he taught me a lot and and
then I I saw this opportunity to to join
at Bay and to view this whole world of
cyber security from a different position
so the first position was very much
biased towards network security and how
and what can you learn about a company
and how can you protect it from um
looking at the network or or residing in
the network endpoint security is very
different but these are basically the
two largest um Fields within cyber
security
the end point was also very very
interesting a lot of details a lot of
the um a lot of things that are related
to how the operating system works and
and bits and bites there and also
learning about the the Security
operation
aspect with at Bay it's a different ER
point of view where you actually look at
risk not specifically at protecting the
network or protecting the endpoints we
we are not looking to create the best
security out there if you look at at
most of the known security cyber
security companies they provide you with
the best you deserve the best security
there's one company that says that um
they're trying to give you the best
security as an insurance company we're
not necessarily looking into the best
we're looking into the the what's what
makes sense what where the ROI lies
there are thing we can compensate our
company our customers when they get
breached it's okay when that happens we
need to statistically lower the the loss
ratio and how much we have we get to pay
back to our customers and that's that's
our main goal that's that's what we're
looking
at wow I I love it and I love how you're
making the distinction for you know look
so positioning of what what are we
looking for looking for where there is
the highest Roi where we can actually
provide real tangible value on real
action actionable claims because the the
industry you know there's a lot of
really scary things that could happen
there's a lot of different ways to to to
create risk but then it's all about what
is actually happening on the field and
and I guess that it is also important
that there's a distinction for for smbs
right and that it's it's different
environment and different experience
than with perhaps you know very large
Enterprises in terms of how they they
think through these sorts of things I
assume right yeah
absolutely um when you look at a large
Bank especially like International
Banks they have the budget they they
sometimes buy products just to have a
proof of concept for a year to try and
and compare this endpoint to another one
or this firewall to a different firewall
and how would it and and they spend
Millions over that they have thems that
are just built to to compare these
products when you go H to an SNB they
don't they're not even aware of all the
options that are out
there they're they're not NE they in
most cases they won't have anyone that
is focused on cyber security H let alone
a security operations team that can
actually operate all those products ER
they they lack some awareness they lack
a lot of um Working Hands and and and
and people like a um a talent Gap that
they suffer from they need the the
people and they usually don't have
budgets to get the the higher end
products we see a lot of second third
tier
endpoint security providers email
security providers all of that so the
challenge is very very different it's
challenge of making the customer aware
uh bringing them solutions that they can
afford themselves and also help them
manage that because they usually don't
have the people to do that it's
very Benny I really want to thank you
for the time and for the insights and
the energy really really awesome um
really love what you guys are doing at
that bay and thank you for sharing you
know the space with me and the insights
and I look forward to sharing this with
the world so thank you so much yeah
thank you for having me
[Music]